here we are now at the end of
all things well the end of the trump
administration so not all things but
that thing at least
joe biden a man with the mental acuity
and
awareness of an oyster is now in the
white house where he will be
taken by the hand guided into a closet
somewhere given some coloring books to
keep them busy
while camilla harris runs the government
and it will be let's face it a radically
far-left government the most far-left
government in american history by a mile
we can pretty much guarantee that
to make matters worse there will be no
constraints there will be uh
no no no restraining it they will be
unfettered they will be free like birds
to fly off and fulfill their
marxist dreams republicans you know
aren't good for much as we've learned
especially when it comes to actually
enacting and acting upon their own
agenda but they can at least play
defense
they're decent at that they can block
the democrat agenda
even if they can't or won't push forward
their own when they have the power
only now they will be unable or
certainly at least less able to block
anything given that the democrats won
georgia and thus the senate
the republicans could have won georgia
if not for the fact that the georgia
race became a
circus sideshow of grifters and carnival
barkers
raising money for their own benefit
while telling republicans to stay home
and forfeit congress to the left
also not helping matters the republican
candidates in those races could not
themselves
have been any less exciting or less
inspiring if they tried and they did try
it seemed
the upshot is that again democrats have
full control and they will exploit that
control to the fullest possible extent
they will show us what it looks like
when power is wielded
make no mistake they will do everything
that they
have the legal right to do and a whole
bunch of things that they do not have
the legal right to do
democrats impose their will when given
the opportunity love him or hate him
and i'm very much a member of the second
club the fact is that
when when when when put into a position
of power the democrats
do what their voters put them there to
do
republicans on the other hand twiddle
their thumbs and bide their time
waiting to be out of power again so they
can finally pretend to care about the
agenda
that they didn't enact when they had the
chance to do it
democrats don't play that game as we
have seen and we will
see even more in the years ahead making
matters worse
the democrats have a taste for vengeance
now taste for blood
they feel that those who inflicted the
last four years upon them those
responsible for making it happen so
you know 75 million people or so should
pay for what they've done
and they are determined to prevent such
indignities
from ever happening again whatever
progress
may have been made in the last four
years whatever good may have been done
it's all mostly stuff that can be easily
reversed and undone
mostly by executive order trump actually
reversed some of it himself on the way
out the door for example rescinding his
own executive order banning
administration officials
from taking lobbyist jobs within within
five years of leaving government
so trump trump saved biden the paperwork
on that one i guess
the rest biden or his handlers can do on
their own without much trouble
meanwhile the conservative movement is
fractured into a million pieces
trump leaves office impeached and
de-platformed facing the possibility of
a senate conviction
many others many other much less famous
conservatives have also been
de-platformed and censored
with the powers that be currently
dreaming up ways to silence the rest of
us
we are under suspicion we are under
attack
the left won by whatever means necessary
and now we are on the outside we are
scattered we are disorganized we are
weakened
that's the reality of the situation it's
best now that we look it straight in the
eyes as uncomfortable as it may be i'm
not here to tell you fairy tales or
delude you into a false sense of
security
the right has been deluding itself for
far too long telling itself stories
about
secret plans and 4d chess and insisting
that everything will magically work out
in the end
up until last night i saw people still
insisting that trump would remain in
office today
and the plan would unfold and everything
would be okay
they held on to the delusion until the
bitter end
some of them probably still holding on
to it even now i wouldn't be surprised
if the new
theory is that trump is really president
still and is secretly running the
government from his batcave
somewhere i'm not joking this is this is
what some people will believe
those of us with the boldness to face
reality though will face it
and reality is as i have described it
here
so the question is what now
where do we go from here what does the
road ahead look like
is all hope lost are we doomed should we
give up
well i can answer those last three
questions with a no no and no
hope is not lost we're not doomed and we
should not give up as for what exactly
happens or what precisely the future
holds that i don't know for certain
nobody does but i do know
that even if we're bruised and beaten at
present we are not in a hopeless state
despair is not the answer and though i
may be
known as a guy who can be quite bleak at
times i'm not exactly a ray of sunshine
i must admit
i have never been in despair and i am
not now and you shouldn't be either
despair is what happens when you have
not only no hope but no meaning in your
life despair is when you wake up and
look around
and you can't see that your life has any
purpose
it's when everything is empty or appears
to be from your perspective
you know i i would hope that nobody
would ever be tempted to feel this way
because of political events
but from the sound and look of it it
seems that some people really are
teetering close to that
it's not that these are trump-obsessed
cultists who can't bear to live without
the man
it's that it's that they they look
around and they see that our government
and our institutions are overrun
and run by people who hate them and they
think it's all lost and there's nothing
ahead but more defeat
and there's no point that's where the
despair comes in
but it shouldn't in fact there is a
silver lining to our present condition
the silver lining is that now
conservatives can stop looking to one
man in washington to save them
and save their families and instead
focus on making an
impact where it really matters and where
it can really be felt
you know the fight going forward is
where it's always been
though we've neglected and ignored it
focusing instead on national politics as
though national politics is the be-all
and end-all
the fight is in our communities it's in
the culture on the local level
the true battle for everything is
happening right around us
right now directly around us
and we can make a profound impact there
if we're willing to put in the effort
let me just give you one tangible
example
the school system millions of children
do you hear me railing about this all
the time millions of children are sent
into these buildings or into zoom
meetings now i guess
where they are conditioned and
indoctrinated into the doctrines of the
far left
yeah we could have only republican
presidents for the next 50 years
it would make almost no difference
culturally as long as we keep feeding
our kids into this system
this is something we can change we can
change it
right now we could but it takes work
it's not always
fun we can pull our kids out we can form
home school co-ops
supporting each other in our communities
taking charge of our children's
education
we can do this we can do that
lots of us are already doing it if
enough of us do it
we can radically change the culture in
immeasurable ways
overnight no matter what anyone in
washington says or does
50 million children are currently
enrolled in public school 50 million
cut that number in half let's say we
could have democrat presidents for the
next 50 years
and that would that would also almost
not matter at all because we will have
so significantly taken back control
of our own families and thus the culture
the condition of the family is what
determines the condition
of the culture
this as i said is just one example there
are plenty of others including in the
realm of politics local politics go to
your town hall meetings figure out who
your local
council members are do you even know
these people have more control over you
than you think
speak out when things are happening in
your neighborhood in community that you
don't like
protest the drag queen story hours this
stuff matters
don't listen to people who tell you it
doesn't
in fact at this point any conservative
who tells you that the culture wars
don't matter
please if if they're going to be any
change we make
disregard them dispense of them throw
them out we don't need them
how can you expect your voice to have
any impact on anything
if there are drag queens performing for
children at your local library two
blocks away
and you say nothing and do nothing about
it
oh we can't do anything about it really
we can't
if all the people in the community that
didn't like it showed up at that library
you don't think that'd be enough to put
an end to it it would
it happens because we don't show up and
we don't
do anything we could
but we don't it's not all a matter of
protesting things either
you know on the other end of it we can
support the people who are making a
positive difference
donate to your local pregnancy center
give to your church get involved in your
church these are all things we can do
there are plenty of other things too it
may not be dramatic or flashy
but the real work of fighting to reclaim
the culture and your country is
rarely dramatic or flashy
the real work is being done by serious
sober-minded people
usually without fanfare and without
notice
that's where our focus should be well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content